[Music]
i rescued george
he was two years old he's not just a
friend
he's family don't move a muscle are you
crazy
don't move
okay very funny you and i laughing at
your joke
new guy he no laugh he cry
you can get up now and check your diaper
come on let's go
wrote your message about george you okay
i don't know
george it's okay
is amir is he considerably bigger no
he's definitely bigger
i need to find someone who knows exactly
what the hell this thing is
i found her nope that's a lie
technically she found us what's
happening to my friend
are you familiar with genetic editing
changes will be incredibly unpredictable
increased strength speed agility
no crowded cells and chains they can't
run
where's george i need to see him he is
dangerous
we're gonna die probably we've created
the next chapter in natural selection
project rampage works you got another
one of your little science experiments
running around what do you mean another
one
it's time we throw everything we can at
these things and get people the hell out
of that city
let's go save the world
that's a big arm don't fight it you know
there are other ways of dealing with
people right
i do know that yeah but that's no fun
george you okay ready to do this buddy
what's that
[Music]
there's a monster outside
what you people discovered is bigger
than we ever thought
possible how big is that thing
it was the largest shark that ever
existed
a living fossil thought to have been
extinct
over two million years wrong
oh my god it's
megalodon he's kidding right
[Music]
[Music]
nothing's out there need to find it and
kill it
why don't you just put a tracker on it
do you guys ever watch shark week
[Music]
he looks heroic but it's kind of got a
negative attitude
chewing this you ugly
[Music]
again
hello
is anyone there
i'm trying to reach
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
senators we believe that these titans
are just the tip of the iceberg
which of these titans are here to
protect us
[Music]
and which of these titans are here to
threaten us
so you'd want to make godzilla our pet
no we would be his
you're sure he's gonna be okay
they're everywhere battling for
dominance
a rival alpha to godzilla
you gotta be kidding
oh
[Music]
we always thought alien life would come
from the stars
but it came from deep beneath the
pacific
what the hell is going on
first kaiju made land in san francisco
the second attack hit manila
then the third one hit cabo
then we learned this was not gonna stop
in order to fight monsters we created
monsters of our own
we needed a new weapon the yeager
program was born
two pilots our minds are
the man and memories become one
today at the edge of our hope
the end of our time
we've chosen to believe in each other
today we face the monsters that are at
our door
today we are cancelling the apocalypse
[Applause]
[Music]
it is pretty cool
pacific rim
[Music]
these are photos of an island in the
south pacific the place where myth and
science meet
horizon we use explosives to shake the
earth helping us to map the surface of
the island you're dropping bombs
scientific instruments
is that a monkey
magnificent you knew that thing was out
here
i'm sorry for your man colonel but if
you want to make their sacrifice
worthwhile
get us home with proof
monsters exist
your friend there can put that down
what the hell is this place that's calm
he's king around here kong's pretty good
king
keeps himself mostly when you don't go
into someone's house and start dropping
bombs unless you're picking a fight
cones god on the island but the devils
live below us
and what are they called i call them
skull crawlers
why never said that name out loud before
it sounds stupid now that i say just
you call them whatever you want
[Music]
it's a good group of boys we're all
gonna die together out here
you shouldn't come here
alien brother believe it and landed in
the wrong place though you get the wrong
place
you discovered a species here the two
are known to science believe
maybe there was a party at the zoo and a
monkey shag to fish
yo check it more what them things ah
lovely fireworks in an invasion of
course it is i'm killing them i'm
killing them
streets let's get to that
quite sweet really aren't they that's
different than him the same thing
that looks triple the stairs
everyone run we need to get off the
streets
back in a block what kind of aliens
would invade some council state in south
london
one that's looking for a fight
what is that
i'm pissing myself in it but at the same
time
this is sick
i've got one text left it's too much
madness to explain in one tank
we have to call the police you'd be
better off calling the ghostbusters now
my name kevin it's me him and his props
whatever kills us no one's gonna ever
call you mayhem
you keep on acting like such a wussy
this is safe
have you seen what's happening out there
[Music]
have you even bothered to look
[Music]
they need to be reminded of the order of
things
turn them on each other
[Music]
one day somebody's gonna have to make a
stand
one day somebody's gotta say enough if i
do this
i do it as a man but you are not just
the man
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
release the kraken
[Music]
listen carefully you are now 5 000 miles
from land
and you're descending seven miles to the
bottom of the ocean
see you all in a month here we go
[Music]
all right we're gonna do this let's do
[Music]
this
i'm gonna scale from one to ten how
bad's my rig
we drilled to the bottom of the ocean
and we don't know what came out
got to get to the station how will you
even get there
we walk we're just gonna walk with
insufficient oxygen across the bottom of
the ocean
you don't know what's out there worst
idea ever
[Music]
what was that it's really tough
what is happening
mom are you positive that there weren't
any other places looking for vice
principles you promise you'll give it a
shot
i promise and i looked into it legally i
can't live on my own until i'm 18.
so you're the new neighbor yeah i'm zach
by the way i'm hannah hammer get away
from the window now i gotta go
hi hey we're just moving in you see that
fence all
stay on your side of it
he's a big teddy bear don't take it
personally he doesn't really like anyone
yeah
oh anna's in trouble oh who's hannah
she's locked in this house and her dad's
a psychopath
does she have a friend
[Music]
oh the abominable snowman of pasadena
these are all goosebumps manuscripts why
are these books a lot
did you unlock a book oh no i'm sorry
i'll put it back where it belongs look
here don't open it
you've just released every monster i've
ever created what was that it's the
invisible boy
uh you're such a cracker
the only way to stop them is to suck
them back into the book
you've read them all right yeah yeah if
we know their weaknesses
we can capture them all we're the only
ones who can do this
oh my god how'd you do that silver
fillings i have a ton of cavities when i
was 10 i didn't brush my teeth for a
whole year
all right everyone find anything you can
to barricade the doors we cannot let the
monsters inside the rules
[Music]
maybe they're friendly not friendly
definitely
[Applause]
i want to talk to somebody in charge
you are not fooling anybody when you say
that what happened was a natural
disaster
you're lying it was not an earthquake it
wasn't a typhoon
because what's really happening is that
you're hiding something out there
and it is gonna send us back to the
stone age
[Music]
in 1954 we awakened something for those
nuclear tests in the pacific
not tests they are trying to kill it
you have no idea what's coming
can you kill it
the arrogance of man is thinking nature
is in our control
and not the other way around
[Music]
[Music]
doesn't even show up on the gps it's
unworthy of global positioning
that's the whole point get off the grid
right
[Music]
hello i'm thinking this thing doesn't
take credit cards
time says closed we're looking for
what's called
tillerman road not to get you there
getting back that's your concern
oh this is awesome
whoa no way
the lambs have passed to the gate they
are come to the killing floor
[Music]
i seriously believe something weird is
going on
what is that thing we have to stay
together
this isn't right we should split up yeah
a good idea
really we gotta get out of here
you're missing the point
[Music]
i think i can get it to go down
i don't want you to die it is real
it isn't real it's just a book
where'd you get this on the shelf
if it's in a word or it's in a look
he wants to scare you first
then you'll see it
this monster thing has got to stop we
can't get rid of the pepper dog
[Music]
you can't get rid of
[Music]
what time is it it's 12 15.
don't do that
[Music]
let's go back to the car
dogs don't caught teeth like this
ma'am you all right yeah we're fine yeah
hamlet's gonna be a bit
stay in there
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Applause]
much
[Music]
mama
[Music]
you